so many families are suffering
so many coronavare's deaths
but amidst the grief there's growing
anger and a building doubt
that the reality doesn't match the
official death figures
this small crematorium in east delhi is
working all hours to keep
up the pyres are close together to try
to fit in as many as possible
and when we visited we counted at least
30
active pyres several ambulances arrived
with more bodies
this alone from one private hospital
brought five dead
in one go another ambulance driver
from a separate hospital told us he'd
been driving all day long
i bring about 10 to 12 bodies every day
he tells us
many of the relatives said they waited
hours to get a funeral space
and they're convinced the tally of
covert deaths is far
higher than being admitted delhi
government
says that 380 people are dying every day
from corona but it's actually
around 1 000 more than 1 000 what do you
base that on how do you know
we know we know because we you we you
know we visit
many hospitals with our patients there
is no
beds available and in criminal area
we searched two or three but there are
no space
then finally we came here
and we are waiting from the last two or
three hours
they're so busy the crematorium is being
extended
with another 100 spaces
the biggest growing industry right now
with most shops closed in the lockdown
seems to be the graveyard business they
told us there's a steady stream of
funerals
throughout the
so day people are dying and brought here
he says daily at least 250 to 300 bodies
are brought here
we see it
all the deaths are meant to be logged
with the funeral officials
so we inquired about the daily figures
just tell me how many yeah what's the
problem between me
just tell me how many have you
registered today how many deaths
how many yeah
the figures are double
and that's just in this crematorium with
18
other official sites in the capital many
of the relatives are deeply suspicious
80 of the debts are due to the medical
negligence here
what i have i have realized we could
have saved them
but they were in hospital they did not
get the proper care what they wanted
and because of the lack of the oxygen
lack of the medicines lack of
injections people are dying here
in neighboring states too there seemed
certain discrepancies about the death
statistics
our researchers in uttar pradesh counted
at least 25 bodies waiting for funerals
and about eight lit in gaziabad and a
lot of angry relatives
frustrated at the process
the official insisted they had an
average of six
deaths and when our researcher
questioned this he was told they'd been
instructed to give that low number
by higher authorities the indian
government insists
all figures are being faithfully
recorded without interference
how many of these deaths could have been
avoided if different decisions had been
taken
alex crawford sky news in new delhi